There's one more thing you can do to protect yourself
from experiencing the symptoms of Alzheimer's,
even if you have the full-blown disease pathology ablaze in your brain.
It has to do with neural plasticity and cognitive reserve.
Remember, the experience of having Alzheimer's
is ultimately a result of losing synapses.
The average brain has over a hundred trillion synapses,
which is fantastic; we've got a lot to work with.
And this isn't a static number.
We gain and lose synapses all the time,
through a process called neural plasticity.
Every time we learn something new,
we are creating and strengthening new neural connections,
new synapses.
In the Nun Study,
678 nuns, all over the age of 75 when the study began,
were followed for more than two decades.
They were regularly given physical checkups and cognitive tests,
and when they died, their brains were all donated for autopsy.
In some of these brains, scientists discovered something surprising.
Despite the presence of plaques and tangles and brain shrinkage --
what appeared to be unquestionable Alzheimer's --
the nuns who had belonged to these brains showed no signs
of having the disease while they were alive.
How can this be?
We think it's because these nuns had a high level of cognitive reserve,
which is a way of saying that they had more functional synapses.
People who have more years of formal education,
who have a high degree of literacy,
who engage regularly in mentally stimulating activities,
all have more cognitive reserve.
They have an abundance and a redundancy in neural connections.
So even if they have a disease like Alzheimer's
compromising some of their synapses,
they've got many extra backup connections,
and this buffers them from noticing that anything is amiss.
Let's imagine a simplified example.
Let's say you only know one thing about a subject.
Let's say it's about me.
You know that Lisa Genova wrote "Still Alice,"
and that's the only thing you know about me.
You have that single neural connection,
that one synapse.
Now imagine you have Alzheimer's.
You have plaques and tangles and inflammation
and microglia devouring that synapse.
Now when someone asks you, "Hey, who wrote 'Still Alice?'"
you can't remember,
because that synapse is either failing or gone.
You've forgotten me forever.
But what if you had learned more about me?
Let's say you learned four things about me.
Now imagine you have Alzheimer's,
and three of those synapses are damaged or destroyed.
You still have a way to detour the wreckage.
You can still remember my name.
So we can be resilient to the presence of Alzheimer's pathology
through the recruitment of yet-undamaged pathways.
And we create these pathways, this cognitive reserve,
by learning new things.
Ideally, we want these new things to be as rich in meaning as possible,
recruiting sight and sound and associations and emotion.
So this really doesn't mean doing crossword puzzles.
You don't want to simply retrieve information you've already learned,
because this is like traveling down old, familiar streets,
cruising neighborhoods you already know.
You want to pave new neural roads.
Building an Alzheimer's-resistant brain
means learning to speak Italian,
meeting new friends,
reading a book,
or listening to a great TED Talk.
And if, despite all of this, you are someday diagnosed with Alzheimer's,
there are three lessons I've learned from my grandmother
and the dozens of people I've come to know living with this disease.
Diagnosis doesn't mean you're dying tomorrow.
Keep living.
You won't lose your emotional memory.
You'll still be able to understand love and joy.
You might not remember what I said five minutes ago,
but you'll remember how I made you feel.
And you are more than what you can remember.
Thank you.
(Applause)